all right party people
this is the time where you let us know
if we are actually live
are we live are we
alive we can let people in
to see that there's a whole thing in
front of us john yeah look at look take
the title away oh my goodness there's a
there's a whole other table here where's
the chat the chat is gonna pop it out
it's gonna pop and lock it
i don't think we're live
i think the playback on this is going to
be great
so that way we're just like huh no one's
here
yeah it's time to tell the truth about
heavy spoilers oh dude
that man
is a con artist he
is a scoundrel and a thief
and you should never trust him
thank you guys very much thank you
thank you uh i know normally we don't go
live at four o'clock
on a saturday afternoon
most people are probably out and about
or whatever so who if you're here thank
you for being here
um and normally i'm not like
please go ahead and contribute to the
stream labs and and uh the super chats
but
today i did one thank you lana thank you
uh if you do contribute to the stream
lads and super chats uh i we're gonna be
donating all of it to
a charity either for um mainly for
domestic violence but there's another
charity that i found that's i was like
what are the charities that speak most
to me personally and it's either one
with domestic violence or one with
animals so odds are anything that's
contributed today
i'm gonna be um splitting it in half to
the ones i already am aware of or have
contributed to in the past as well so
please i will encourage you guys that
anything you guys contribute today in
this stream it will all go toward we
won't be streaming for that long and i
really mean that because i do have a
gathering uh today with a select group
of people
but i just wanted to you know encourage
it i wanted to do something good
today so yeah anyway
thanks guys let's just hang out now uh
yeah i am uh i am 46 years old
i don't have a girlfriend i am a virgin
uh mateo uh scott cluna i am not 32
but i appreciate the compliment tan the
conqueror if you're not 64 my friend
you're 64 my friend i have not grown all
that much thank you david gandy for
contributing we will get to all the you
know what i want to really encourage
today that pete because i want to help
raise a little bit more money for some
charity today so john can we really
quickly pull up the people who we only
got three people four people have
already contributed to the super chats
and i just wanna i normally wait a
little bit of time but uh today i would
like to encourage it just because i
really want people to uh help contribute
it's all going to charity today and i
want to make sure that people feel
inclined we're not just taking the money
for squeezy
nah nah this is purposeful this john
turned 45 this year so you had to do me
by turning 46. you know disney fan uh i
was and it's always sunny in
philadelphia in the first season i had a
line in there and i was watching uh on
my downtime uh i watched uh it's always
sunny in philadelphia i was on season
like 13 or 14
and they reference like we're not
throwing another underage drinking party
and i was like holy [ __ ]
that was the episode i was in
and it reminded me like oh yeah
i gotta have a little line one line on
one of my all-time favorite shows
and that's pretty crazy
when i think about it like holy crap i
gotta have a line on one of my all-time
favorite shows not many people get to
say they gotta do that so they should
give you a royalty for mentioning your
episode again now the 46 thing is good
click bait
yeah because then everybody has this
same response yeah what just works it
gets you to click and be like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you who are you even
uh yeah so let's john can we scroll
through record here on the main screen
thank you guys so much for being here
and yeah like i said any and all super
chats or stream labs too uh they take
less fees so any and all any and all the
contributions today will be going to
charity
um let's see lana.org lana you've been
around here for a while thank you so
much for being here lana um just an
absolute doll
happiest is that offensive to say adult
like you're an absolutely you are that
offensive
um i feel like it's less offensive than
just calling somebody hey doll you know
so i think uh that's that's a bit
complimentary still but hey comment if
you're offended
yeah lana tell us if you want a refund
yeah but no if you want a refund you're
taking it away from charity taking it
away from a worthy cause
happiest of birthday wishes to mr nipple
chills himself yes uh feels like just
yesterday that i discovered your channel
through a bvs trailer reaction was it
one of the ones where we i love the
trailer or the one when we didn't love
the trailer uh glad to be in the reject
nation happy b day greg thank you so
much and uh your contribution means a
lot
so yeah like i said i'm just gonna i
just have to keep reminding you as
people keep coming in that um anything
that severely offended dislike
that anyone who uh contributes today
it'll all be going to charity
bucky barnes hey
joe
yep our moderator happy birthday
you look young because you're that's
guardian thank you thank you thank you
for contributing to charity today and
you are of the galaxy so that's perfect
um thank you guys for being here um so
much you know it's a random hour of the
day and i'm a little tired i was on set
i can't say what i was on set for
i orbee is too i was sh i had a morbius
too i'm shadowing the director of
morbius too i gotta learn how he makes
the magic you gotta bring back all the
post-credits scenes to let people know
about now
i'm i'm shadowing um
i got a random late opportunity and uh
i'm shadowing a director of a netflix
original scripted series
and and uh the first day it was like all
right 4 30 p.m till 5 30 a.m so i was up
really late and i learned so much and
you know what uh it really
i kept saying this to some of the crew
because what a lot of people don't
realize with filmmaking is it takes like
20 to 30 minutes on average to set up a
shot and that shot can be just to
capture
literally a few seconds most of the time
it's just a few seconds less than a
minute
and it takes 20 to 30 minutes just to
set up that one shot on average some of
them took longer
and then i've kept talking to some of
the crew about it of i can't believe
they cancelled batgirl
like that's where my thought went is
can you imagine that all that labor to
get seconds like
and on a movie bigger than what i was
i'm on set for a pretty decent sized
budgeted netflix show
oop kind of gave a little bit more than
i wanted to give away there's a stranger
um
however uh the
just to witness that it just reminded me
like yeah this is what i mean by this is
how much hard work because you got like
countless people just
coming together to bring together a few
seconds capture a few seconds you got to
do retakes on and then you got to put it
together in any room so
yeah
i'm actually 50. i was just trying to
feel better about myself
um thank you a man that's really kind to
you uh let's move on here david gandy
one of our most loyal followers and also
just an amazing friend yeah says
happiest of birthdays greg thank you for
all you do thank you for all that you do
you've been a major he's given us the
camera yeah we're looking forward to
streaming off of right through gandy
vision so thank you
thank you very much i don't know what's
more it's and now i know the feeling
that you had john when i said you were
45 yeah people believe you're actually
like okay and like you actually look
good for that then i'm like oh my god
you're actually oh leave it what does it
say about it's plausible
okay all right i guess i am
um it's good so yeah it's good let me
see here
uh thank you again any and all you guys
contribute today we'll go to charity uh
film geeks hey film geeks happy birthday
greg you guys are an inspiration of all
of us hopefully john's buying you dinner
tonight no what john bought me today oh
no beyond some egg salads he got me this
friend's
lego set
no i got excited about this i think i've
seen it before at the lego store and i
was like oh i want to get that yeah
never did so thank you yeah it's a start
and then you'll get the the all the
apartments and then you'll have like a
whole friend set you can make brick
films on i can't wait to give this to
charity yes
the animals will love it i know you're
suffering with terrible domestic
violence issues yes so here's a lego set
for you today to
rebuild your life and it's metaphorical
today that's right
uh all right guys
let's keep moving aaron ryder
uh here for both b days happy birthday
greg thank you aaron ryder for being
both for john's earlier and now mine
really appreciate it your contribution
means a lot
so this is at my age online
i'll find out later is my age online
what do you guys tell me
y'all are definitely 37. all of us are
37. i am like a kid brother to john uh
cammy d never pooed in my life
definitely the most immature we will be
covering cobra kai season five this week
so don't don't you worry we'll be
covering it shouts out to andrew gordon
um
ooh i'm going to tell you something
good i can't say [ __ ]
maybe not sleeves i gotta get so careful
of what i say here
shout out to andrew tell you about some
stuff um yeah can we refresh that andrew
gordon's at the very top of that yeah
all right what's going on in the actual
chat
anything you guys contribute today going
to charity just a friendly reminder so
thank you thank you all
matthew cronin i know i i know i don't
look 46 but i definitely feel 46. it's
just a part of life
placencia bernal rodrigo happy birthday
greg have an incredible time and take
care of yourself and a question when
they react to the animated movie the
next avengers heroes of tomorrow is an
incredible movie i actually have not
seen that movie i might add it to the
list here oh boy
it's been added
you didn't see the chat's not moving oh
sorry
let me see here i appreciate that i i
think i like to think i'm a fine looking
46 year old you are you know what i mean
now if i was 32 something might look off
but 46 i think i look pretty damn good
but what if we hate charity
well
that's your that's a issue that you
gotta resolve within yourself i suppose
nah
you know you don't have to give there
should be a charity for people who hate
charity look guys i know online that it
says i'm 32 but guys look people lie all
the time and i don't want to be one of
those influencers who bullshits you guys
i'm 46 years old just treat me like my
age all right i'm really 46
adult
dakota jones
yes love love you so much buddy thank
you dakota i love you too you've been
around for so long have a beautiful day
you have a beautiful day dakota thank
you for your contribution beautiful
today's charity
louis libits happy birthday greg just
got back from no way home more fun
version i think i want to like when it
comes out online i want to just like
do a reaction highlights to just the
deleted scenes
and then be like this wouldn't work
ha ha
i didn't see it in the context of how
they put it back to the film right yeah
yeah yeah just cut it all out and then
yeah do a medley like it's an actual
special features menu
first time super chatter been a fan
forever and you all rock thank you you
rock cause you gave the charity today my
friend anyone who gives charity is a
good person in my mind
lana.org back at it dude just want to
donate more
here here are you still influencing
influencers stuff i think you were doing
like modeling or something before right
lana are you still doing that go follow
her online if you want people to i don't
i don't know some people get weirded out
if you don't plug it but i don't know i
don't remember lana's public social
media
[Laughter]
let me see happy birthday ryan ryan's
happy for me ryan is uh and he's got a
different birthday from you it's the
weirdest thing
shane white i saw dragon heart in the
theaters like three times i am the last
one
the last rock i am the lost one well i'm
trying to do it i am the lost wife
i don't think he says dragon no probably
not i think he just turns to dennis
quaid
it says i slept with meg ryan
and then i slapped on the face
because you can do that to women if
you're sean connery
uh yeah and your boy david thulas you're
your favorite pervert oh you're her only
fan's going strong good for you lana um
oh spiderman lotus director came out
with an apology
all right i gotta re-upload that
reaction and act like i hated that
trailer yeah
and the special effects that are still
getting love online
um olente thank you so much
that means a lot
again any you know you contribute going
to charity today boom you guys are like
superman and batman
which one am i
john which one am i you'd probably be
batman thank god
because you're cool and you're brooding
and you like that is me i'm you
like hyper focus and you like superman
everything comes easy well you know
superman just like listens and then he
flies out you know he doesn't have to do
as much detective work you know he's not
as in depth under the hood as batman you
know he's got gifts he doesn't have to
rise above his humanity that's very true
whereas batman does
crowman27 thank you so much for your
contribution today you're definitely
batman and it looks like the chat agrees
yeah
if there was only a one percent chance
it could be batman
we have to take in his absolute
certainty
i've had 46 birthdays can't lie oh but
mike rodias in the in the chat thinks
you're superman ah well he doesn't know
what he's talking about yeah which is
exactly what batman would say oh you
don't know what you're talking about
bucky's got him all right claudio
rogohan
you you're you actually 46 yeah yeah
yeah rio 46 real real 46 years old
updated on the website the new channel
name will be the real 46. but jaby coway
my brother looks up to me so much
yes like 30 year older brothers and
inspiration
in in three months jaby coway turns
young young lad that jaby kawaii
somebody in the chat knows the deep cuts
we went to the same school as david
henry and friends with him he's not 46.
greg and john were held back we were
held back 12 years
yeah we were held back 12 13 years and
david henry um
you know he was ahead of his his way
ahead of the curve there so
um but yes
hi greg my name's cassidy they them
hello cassidy how's it going and it's
also my birthday today what do you know
hey happy birthday happy birthday you
just turned 21. oh my god go to a strip
club you could have done that three
years ago what are you holding out on
but you can go to uh uh uh like one with
where they wear the bottoms but you get
to drink
i like it there you go would be
interested in watching more cartoons
like amphibia i've never heard of
amphibia let's google it
i'll google it on the small computer so
that we can keep the super chat why not
live i'll get it going keep it going
alive here anything you guys contribute
today all goes to charity so i really
appreciate it the poster for amphibia
looks cool yeah where's the supers how
do you bring it back oh they're going
away oh no everything's broken no it's
just us exposed oh what's happened there
you go there's here there's your dingus
there okay what happened where did the
window go well we're going to open up a
new super chat window it's going to be
even better than the old one if you guys
don't contribute today you obviously
don't care about domestic violence and
animals who are endangered and also are
uh need help in uh pet sanctuaries yeah
you you're you're directly in opposition
if they're not today i'm gonna guilt
everyone into contributing
no that's the way to do it that's the
way to do it
especially when it comes to charity
amphibia what channel is it on it's a
diddly uh show it's a disney animated
and uh here brenda's song brenda song
she's an awesome lady look at the look
at the poster for this look at all these
creatures
got a lot of adventure
yeah yeah nothing's more exciting than
watching john pull up a laptop close to
his face guys like look at look at what
i'm looking at look at who's your
imagination all right well here up here
um
master of getting distracted mr john
humphrey over here
uh you know sometimes it depends
sometimes especially if there are
photographs to be taken then yes oh this
is a great new window i love that this
new window has given me the opportunity
to search
there we go amphibia there you go peeps
that's for that's for all y'all look at
that it's going look at that that's
amazing maybe one day i've never heard
of this show and you are the first
person to have ever mentioned it so
maybe one day we'll cover it either way
appreciate
your charitable contribution today boom
so much all right let's get back down
there john this chat keeps freezing and
i want to make sure we i can constantly
see the chat there's any way to get that
going there you go we're looking forward
to chuckie season two yeah of course
absolutely i'm so excited i was in the
car the other day with a few people who
were like i hate that chucky show what i
was like go to hell who the hell were
you in a car with i can't say their
names they are terrible human beings wow
in a car
hey greg and jerry i still think your
team sure do you think the shield show
is stupid because i've heard it's not
getting the audience it wants i like it
i like she-hulk
i i like it uh i like it
and we're the audience that hates
anything marvel related so that's right
it's a rare occasion that greg and john
like marvel related content
i like it i think it's fun not a big old
marvel guy
i i like the third episode i like the
least even though anytime a new episode
comes out of anything people are like
this might be my favorite episode people
always say that i'm not saying you're
wrong or you're just lying to yourself
um it is uh i i personally was not as
big of a fan of the third episode i like
this first and second one more
connie's saying hey connie my dear honey
got a package here waiting to open it
today
you know what [ __ ] it let's open it
let's do it i'm gonna go get it i think
it's right here yeah yeah we got i got a
package delivered
to the p.o box
do we have a blade
a blade it says a24 on it so connie i
hope you're watching
alexander24 that's what the a stands for
if you go to the kitchen john i'll go to
the kitchen uh by where the water jug is
if you open the cabinet you should be
able to find the batman knife
i will hold down the chat here
for a little bit anyway
oh sono do valena happy birthday i am
from brazil and i always accompany you
good health lots of love lots of sex and
lots of movies lord knows i'm doing all
those but lots of sex and not really
much movies
you're joking about being 46 right you
all look 30 at most
we look 30 at most can you believe that
[ __ ]
this guy doesn't believe that i'm
actually 46. i'll take it happy birthday
greg you have reached a great mile
johnny blaze gaming in here what's going
on buddy yo yo yo
sarah williamson trust me you look way
younger than me even though i'm five
years older than you mm-hmm don't worry
sarah you're killing it connie are you
in the chat all right sweet connie's
watching
watching connie
all right let's see what's going on here
second angle
let's get another angle
oh yeah don't worry i'll i'll learn how
to open a box in a second here i'm going
to refrain from guessing
if you're just getting into the chat
first things first anything you guys
contribute today is all going to a
charity either for domestic violence or
for an animal
sanctuary secondly um i'm going to
divide it up and secondly i have a uh
a present here from connie that was
delivered
and uh i want to see what it is
what do we got is it is it an everything
everywhere
a24 audit auditor of the month
oh
oh i get it how it is everything
everywhere got the award
took me a second to get it but i was
like oh wait [ __ ] yeah
oh man we're about to get demonetized
how do we i know i i it's got the googly
eyes on it from everything everywhere
i don't want to cut the ribbon don't cut
the ribbon ah [ __ ] just never open it
damn it uh oh i could open it from the
bottom yeah there you go perfect
and you gotta marcel the shell with
shoes on postcard
i don't mind ruining the bottom if that
means i can preserve the ribbon
already bone
if you guys haven't seen everything
everywhere all at once first of all
reaction got age restricted which really
pissed me off but it kind of makes sense
secondly
um
secondly uh one of the producers the
head producer that hit me up
and uh said some very nice words so very
really proud that's my favorite of the
year oh wow auditor of the month oh wow
it's what um it's it's what they fought
with
yeah yeah we can we can fight to sit on
it later oh it's a candle lookie there
and i might be seeing
the guy who had this plugged in him
during the fight sometime soon
and so i got to take a photo of this to
show him like hey i actually have that
thing
but it's not oh it's a candle yeah but
it's not the one
that
uh he put in his butt himself
unfortunately but i love this thank you
connie that's awesome thank you does it
smell like a butt
no no it smells like it smells fresh
smells like uh what's on the paper asian
man's vagina yes um it's just a receipt
cool
thank you
read the recipe beautiful candle i can't
wait for my mom to come by and see this
candle
oh yeah and uh where's that box there
okay perfect there you go you gotta
preserve the ribbon there you go thank
you so much
thank you anything you guys contribute
today we'll go to charity today
leah aryabani love you greg happy
birthday oh thank you leah that means a
lot i love you too
i love you too
i know this gift is awesome isn't it
just got this gift from connie auditor
of the month candle my god
it does feel good
i agree preparation does feel good on
the whole i'm actually not high um
that'd be nice he's a soberist for
everyone
um yeah
[Music]
the not being high sound effect i
appreciate that
good to have you in my corner
random happy birthday greg do you think
that we're going to get the f forecast
of d23 god i hope so see notification
bells through the roof about it
as if it's news john krasinski will be
there
to announce who else is playing
everybody's every day fantastic
forecasting update fantastic forecast it
was like when spider-man no way home was
coming out casting update it's still
going to happen d23 they're still gonna
tell us who confirmed at d23 is when
they're gonna they just wanna know who's
playing who
i hope the reaction when it comes out is
huh
i don't know i don't like any of these i
don't know about that
everyone they cast is 46.
marvin martin marvin martin thank you if
you could pick on b day wish to become
real
or if you could pick a b day wish to
become real
uh
it would be
i want to say something sweet
and philathromp
but it would be to win the lottery
that would be my birthday wish
win the lottery and then not know what
to do with the money go broke within six
months and then wither and die
that would that would be my birthday
wish perf mark coffee
happy hundredth birthday greg i know
you're a highlander there can only be
one
you have a good one oh yeah man i'd be
uh
god i really want to tell you guys about
the thing because sometimes you guys
mention something in the chat i really
want to tell you about this show that i
was fortunate i was shadowing a direct
shadow director on a set yesterday and i
saw
some some of the footage they have
edited so far
and this shows it's going to be awesome
and i can't give away who's involved in
it or anything but
[ __ ] it is it is going to be such an
awesome show i i was there going look i
need to get this through to you this is
going to be great like i don't i'll be
honest i haven't seen much of the edited
scenes like in terms of his characters
talking
but the action scenes
that i haven't seen a show that has done
this just yet and is so good that's all
i'll say
um i have heard of the lottery curse and
i'm willing to take the gamble uh dr
stinky
distinct happy birthday man 32 i don't
know what's 32 around here what do you
rate she-hulk
it uh i'd probably say like a 7.5 out of
10 for me i rate the first episode one
out of nine the second one two out of
nine the third one three atom
but the good thing is it keeps going up
it keeps going by the ninth episode it's
gonna be perfect claudio
rogahan aren't you like 32 that's what
the internet says who is this internet
you keep talking the internet lies look
my publicist didn't want people to know
my actual age because they thought i'd
be having a hard time
booking gigs as an influencer for me to
go out there to do red carpet events to
attend all kinds of fan conventions so
that way i could plug things and be like
wow just announced can't believe it guys
best news in the world
they thought it would sound weird coming
from a 46 year old so they lied and said
i'm 32 and so i fired that publicist
it's like good riddance i'm gonna be me
i want to be me a 46 year old man who
still shouts at trailers
sean roebuck
thank you guys so much just got engaged
happy birthday congratulations
congratulations
it's everyone in the back is she he they
them hot
i hope you're attracted to them
[Laughter]
unseen we have been married
engaged i should say damn sir you've
been here a long time thank you so much
for being here so long that means a lot
yeah click on this button by my dick to
subscribe
classic man bring it back the not so
great gatsby don't you mean the greg
gatsby
happy 21st can't you tell us how you got
on sunny well it's simple
like most people who have one line you
audition
like
but
like 50 other actors go in there to try
to get that one lock he's got to climb
the ladder you gotta pay your dudes yeah
you gotta prove your worth
um i'm pretty sure i only got it because
the cast director that day kept messing
up her lines and she kept laughing at
herself messing up and i wasn't like a
dick about it
and uh it's not like me saying what is
he like 40 is the hardest thing to get
down
so i'm pretty sure i got it out of like
i feel bad for what i put this guy
through here
so give him a party it's not like you
watch me say that line and you have no
idea who i am and you're like i don't
know who this guy is
this guy that's a good place that's an
amazing delivery
we gotta we gotta book this guy ben
that's greg's skincare routine will be
up on the channel this week but if you
guys have seen it's always sunny in
philadelphia what's funny to me is i
never saw that episode until years later
because when i when i when i was on the
show
um
you know it was it was the underage
drinking episode of the first season so
it's in this mansion and you're there
all day to shoot one line because that's
how it goes on these things and
um
what what happened was there was uh
it was it was it was mac
um rob mc i still know i said his last
name like mcgowan
i think it's michelani
rob
lenny i'm disappointed in myself i
clarified this with coy because he knows
so there's yeah he's irish
rob mcclelhan
and then charlie day and they were the
ones kind of directing the scene
and uh watching them
uh
laugh hysterically at me saying what is
he like 40
was not flattering because i thought
this show was gonna be utter [ __ ]
and this script was awful to me because
i'm like a 14 year old kid going like
what is this this is so stupid and
terrible no one's gonna watch this and
now it's one of your favorites
years later i started it and i was like
this is funny and then it's one of my
all-time favorite shows and it's so
addicting
and uh it is kind of crazy to be like
man my 14 year old brain did not
understand what they had on their hands
that'd be one of the longest running
live live action sitcoms
um so yeah conquer king
we got a pretty bitching king the
conqueror shirt coming out uh hopefully
next week should be or else i'm gonna
get in major trouble
but it should be coming out next week
happy birthday dude love and appreciate
the reactions you do thank you so much
we do like reacting
um my imdb i'm on imdb still i need to
take that [ __ ] down let's look it up i
want to be associated with the internet
movie database it makes me sound biased
you are uh only toward pictures anything
you guys contributed today goes to
charity
getting that out there
phillip svartsved
i'm not gay but you look a bit too sexy
craig too sexy for your shirt i get that
a lot oh yeah a girl came up to me today
and said i don't know who you are
but
you look like a hot 46 year old
i know a few 46 year olds you're the
hottest i'm a hot 46 year old man
50 never looks so good hey that's
offensive all right i'm so close to 50
that i'm i'm dreading it
i don't want to age to 50 man
nah great kill yourself
no
maybe on a live stream
greg's euthanasia live stream to the
domestic violence charity
while we've cranked jokes about offering
ourselves on his live chain well that's
your job what was that girl's name
olivia
was no is what is that girl's name and
her name is libya
greg jay
thank you for the moment of silence as
john likes to say yeah that's us
me and you shared account i personally
always thought greg and john were secret
brothers
why would we be secretive about that you
know how much more we could capitalize
it on that oh my brothers react or some
[ __ ] yeah my brother wants to do i
was born a minute before you
are we real twins nah frankie gouge
yes thank you for contributing to
charity today
today's my birthday too wish that i was
46 years young again frankie gouge age
is just a number granted it does weigh
on your soul and there can be some you
know physiological effects
on top of that too you know if you want
to have children it's better to start
younger yeah and also with career
pursuits yeah you can you know
you don't have to be young to succeed
but odds are that you probably should
have invested that time at an
earlier age
but no age just a number
that's it
it's just a number doesn't mean anything
it doesn't correspond to anything
i can't believe how much younger john
looks especially his skin and hair and
eyes and lack of greg wrinkles
greg ring greg wrinkles trademark that
dude gregor wrinkles ooh i'm detective
greg ringles
how sarah williamson wants to know how
much it would be for me to shave your
head for the next live stream
it would be a travesty if i shaved your
head can't do it it'd be worse if i
shaved your head than it would be if i
shave my money can can force me to shave
my head
maybe three thousand dollars
no money but maybe enough money
but no 3 000 that's that's pretty decent
um yeah
any uh
anything you ask attributed goes to
charity
elmist
happy birthday greg
thank you almost
have you guys ever seen severance
no but it is one of those shows where
people you know that age-old thing that
when you're in a conversation
and they're like oh my god oh my god
have you seen
severance you seen ted lasso
are those two shows
you haven't team severance
there's only like three shows out there
and you haven't seen one of the three
that's right man catch up catch up on
one of the three shows
oh hey someone wants to know that you're
filipino i am so
i'm half filipino
and you're guapo the boot hail the doll
don't worry we won't shave any heads no
heads shaving john especially refuses to
cut his hair
no
i can never go back to the forbidden
kingdom
oh yes bronson plays
raw okay yeah bronson plays believe it
or not this was the an actual thing i
considered just but due to the fact of
what the specific live stream is
we have your video we found it i promise
you we actually found it it's on the
desktop it's on the desktop right here
and a big part of it but because i
wanted to keep this going and it's a
short amount of time and it's for
charity today
that's the only reason why like the next
time we will i promise like i know i
promised that last time but this is a
very specific last-minute decision and
and everything's for charity today so
like we will i prom like it's right i
could see it so yeah
it was an actual consideration like do
we do this in this stream or should we
wait for the next one
rosie what do you what do you mean ted
last night hold on we have to read it if
you react to this oh thanks oh i'm sorry
i'm trying to read it
yeah i read it but i didn't read it out
loud and the audience can't read it well
cool then we'll be right back with the
real rejects audience none all of them
are illiterate everyone can't everyone
can read you're insulting their
intelligence by not letting me read it
for them i didn't mean to condescend to
all of you guys okay let's bring the
agents and greg and jaby well jaby is 30
um in two months i'm 46. 16-year age
difference and two months he's been
playing catch up ever since and honestly
when he hit a million subscribers before
us on the jaby kawai channel filled with
jealousy how could my younger brother do
this for me
i was so upset pissed off and raged
and uh now
as i'm aging 50 i realize i gotta let
the little things go you do it's good
for especially for like your blood
pressure and things like that yeah
cholesterol
be much healthier with less stress yeah
also i will have a large pizza tonight
you should it's your birthday
and and happy late night sweden to you
orco oscar thank you to you in sweden
late at night i'm gonna play a little
fun experiment here because i love our
audience demographics sure all right
guys guys
if you're a man
put down i am a man
if you're a woman
put down i'm a woman
uh you should give him another option
because the genders thing john john's
making a pull
there you go
yeah yeah
get it going oh my god john are you
trying to find a funny one no i did i
thought i was uh asking the community
jesus master of distractions
it's me
that's that's oh here we go all you have
to do is hit one button i know
now
now you're starting over oh my goodness
i know it was the most complicated
master of destruction
hey man you asked for it i just i just i
just make the polls we're gonna make a
pull here
so we can see how limited our our female
demographic
guys we need to increase our female demo
back when i was going by ryan wright i'm
telling you the the female demographic
was like four percent so now and now
it's like
almost 20 so i'm like okay dude that's
five times what it uses it's all because
of this guy all because of this guy
that's right man sarah i mean being 46
it's all about proper skin care regime
garnier
fructis for the hair the classic greg
product dove
lotion
for the face exfoliant
and um you know eating a lot
of pinto beans for gut health yeah
through
yeah
75 look at that man pole climbing do the
show look at the man pole climbing no
show it oh no show it he is female all
right guys let's keep going justin
martin justin martin just brilliant man
over here justin martin thank you for
contributing charity today happy
birthday man thanks for being awesome
and always inspiring slash hilarious
i'll meet you on the inspiring but
hilarious
i don't know i don't buy it been a fan
since
20 what do you guys think about louis
ck's comeback uh he's on every podcast
this week all of a sudden he went on one
podcast and everyone's like we're good
he's good we can we're fine we can put
him on podcast now no more controversy
good all of his panels
have been forgiven
everything you donate to this stream
will be given to louis ck brandon in the
chat brandon melgar beam out my fiance
right now for uh gathering we're having
later today
been a fan since 2014 and happy to see
how far you guys have come we have come
so far and on many things so thank you
guys
were your headsets called we we stole
them off of a plane crash yes these
pilots died and we were like oh my god
they're still alive we could call the
ambulances or
we could take their headsets if we just
peel the melted skull flesh off these
headsets we could use these in the
studio
yes yeah yeah some guy gets the ryan
right scroll up a tad bit very slow
because you tend to be like
it's not a roulette game john oh my god
okay too slow
[ __ ] tortoise and hair race jesus
christ what's going on
you know what never mind hey shouts out
i saw some people shouting out doctors
control f the word dick
not showing up no it's too late somebody
understood that there's a big difference
he pointed out wonderfully all right
let's go back to the
i think they might have deleted their
message it's messed up man i'm about to
shout your card they did i was about to
shout out your comments
could you marco santos happy b day dude
enjoy your day we will i'm especially
happier that you guys today whoever's
contributing is going all this is going
to charity so this means a lot
john please keep scrolling there you go
there you go you got it back oh kylie
said yeah watch domestic old reactions
and the dick badgio quotient was super
high that was the those were the days
that was one of them now i just got this
uh
evocative candle on screen today yeah
now you're much more subtle in your
perverted humor yeah
hey
s
cinnamon can can i have this mouse first
please
i want to see the pull
oh
it's going well to pull
how are you just click it yeah just
click the bar there you go all right
poll
this is about actor out of 297 this is
what our demographics reflected
i am a man
seven wait can you put the poll on
screen sure
what time is it it's all the time
for real time it is
at
505. okay okay
arctic motion antarctic monkeys right
now i think we you guys are contributed
plenty for today honestly any little
amount uh is great you know this is this
is amazing this is amazing
um
all right here you make this little
smaller
let's see it let's see it all right
here's the poll guys right in front of
our faces
uh
there you go okay 73 male
22
woman
5 gender fluid non-binary all right now
um john can i see this now again
absolutely i'm going to do
is i'm going to pull up our analytics on
youtube
is this logged in to uh youtube yeah
okay how we're streaming i'm gonna pull
up our analytics on youtube and i'm
gonna see
what our
demographic is okay
on um
gender yeah do it
uh which is somewhere your life
okay
um i'm gonna go through the last let's
do 2022. okay
20 22
22.
our audience
is actually
84.6
male female
15.3 percent
so this is not too far off
i would say we're doing a little better
in this chat do a little better in this
short little live stream today okay good
to know good to know we got to increase
that female audience we do
not genuinely strictly algorithmic
purposes yeah i don't actually care
about women or what they think or
anybody who's not a man wait do they
like to be called they what's offense
that do these things nowadays
it is the worst one
that
it would be amazing to have a more um
gracious female
audience
woman in the chat what do you want to
see more of yeah what would appeal more
to you what would it from us tell us
what you want
like any man in a relationship just tell
me so i can make you with me tell me
what it is you want stop playing passive
aggressive
just tell me
all right so uh oh wow lb dropping
dropping factoids in the chat about us
jeez listening to those damn albee
you're blowing my cover today listen to
those old q and a's don't listen to lb
she's a woman liar i'm 46. it's funny
sometimes i'll think of the old
questions that you guys used to ask now
on the q a that we used to do on patreon
and be like oh man i have such a better
answer for that now
and uh lb some of those questions were
yours
yeah but uh what uh what no don't change
what do you guys want to see ladies i
would love it if there was eden these
are audio technica i would i would love
it
if
somehow we figured out like oh if we do
more of these videos
we get more of a female audience yeah
and then to start getting so much crap
on twitter
for being like they change they just
started doing videos to tend to a female
audience like how would they know that i
know how would they know unless somebody
clipped this exact moment
from the past smile more tacos she was
[ __ ] up oh i was watching elvis last
night k14 are you i want to hear from
the women in the chat i didn't know for
sure
as much of a joke as it is like it's an
actual question as well because this is
a rare opportunity this is market
testing we get to go ladies what do you
guys like what do you guys want to see
is it just you know is it just the
wokeness of the rings of power is that
what makes you happy doesn't seem to
make anybody happy oh cat i'm sorry you
got covered kova's awful man believe me
i got it from someone in this room
ah
that's messed up
i'm having a few people come over today
just a small handful of people
and i bought covet tests
and never everyone to take him like
you're not coming in here to go
everyone's just standing in a circle
again
all right let's pull back up the super
chats uh while we i'll be reading this
don't worry
more
reactions or emotional side
you might be right about that rosie oh
hi rosie by the way i'm so used to
seeing you hi rosie there are lots of
classic rom-coms i've never seen leah we
did read your super chat yeah that's
true
um lots of classic rom-coms horror film
reviews
i just joined by but i am a woman why
was i subbing
what do you want to see get a little
commotion for the woman in the chat
shirtless calendars we could do that in
our shop zero i gotta get the marvel
body first i think i
if you wanna know my actual honest
thought i actually think it might be
more solo john videos
i noticed
okay
i'm trying to like get rid of my
sarcastic tone and just talk genuinely
for a second
i noticed
this might sound strange um i tend to
appeal more
to like gay men than i do
hetero woman sure john tends to appeal
more to hetero women
than gay men
and honestly it makes a lot of sense to
me
i would love to hear the breakdown i
don't know i don't know why but i'm like
no
it lines up
makes sense
okay i can see it yeah okay
i can i can i can kind of fathom where
you might be coming i do notice this
wasn't intentional our disney movie
reactions tend to be more female
audiences and i didn't i i that wasn't
an intentional thing on our m but i'm
like oh this is actually like like
usually almost 50 yeah
marcus santos can we look up the chats
here
surely oh i am a woman i want to make a
reaction to harley quinn's animated
series go make a reaction then do it oh
my god and that would be a great
perspective
i've seen all of it
i've seen none of it i love all your
videos as a woman viewer thank you oh
thank you
69maker.com says
uh
69mega.com is being hidden from the
channel um oh and and hey just really
quick if any of you guys are in our
comment thread and you get a comment
saying that you've won something from a
channel that looks like ours but very
very weird ass name very real they're
like i've i've got hundreds of so many
videos reporting and blocking and then i
just keep making sure to keep setting up
new accounts that way you don't miss it
those are all legitimate
give out your personal information
even though we never talk about our
contest in a video so yeah just letting
you know it's all real it's all me oh
set up accounts you're getting a call
from the boss
what do you mean she calling me yeah
where is she she's right there
oh sorry it's okay can you meet my
headset for one second john um
yeah buddy all you can hear is me
oh look out now
okay so we got
streets of fire i've never seen that
would be cool i don't know what the the
demand is for that um
solo reactions okay so ladies want solo
reactions gotcha i like it see this is
the weird part where you're like i don't
want to talk too much over this phone
call ask
a store that they think would be a good
place to pick up some chairs
what do you think would be a good place
to pick up some folding chairs guys
comment below maybe like a hardware or
like a target or like something what
about target have you tried target i bet
they would have a folding chair
or yeah i mean anything ex
all right i don't want you to go like
crazy here people can stand they don't
have to be lazy
go go stand go stand at the birthday
ooh mayor of east town
because i'm gonna do so much cocaine
tonight once i take all this
oh yeah all this charity money is going
on and give it to the cocaine dealer
it's a charity to my dealer who really
needs to turn his life around
oh we could wear tank tops while
watching reactions i would just need to
to start lifting but that would give me
a good excuse to start okay so people
are saying
topless could the chat hear my cocaine
joke not at all
nobody heard you ordering cocaine
don't worry
just me and my earphone i would suggest
prepper for anybody who wants it you'll
buy a shirtless calendar or hail a bell
you'll be the only customer uh crispy
nugget says that you should watch
sandman if you want to attract more gay
people
i i i am that's mainly what i attract
already so i will watch sandman on the
channel and we will get female life are
you going to watch sandman at all sarah
we went to costco and we couldn't find
it um anyway
uh dc animated movie reactions i wish i
didn't see most of them already ah
bummer
all right again john hasn't though uh i
haven't i would love to watch more so
maybe that's the key i would be super
duper thrilled by any and all i'll watch
rom-coms i will watch these animated
movies it's all the women in the chat
none of you are showing up to any of
these areas increasing their male
demographics i've never seen final
destination uh not gonna do any of
jeepers creepers
the master of distractions
so we got to read the people that
contributed to charity today because
anything that is contributed
ghost charity cinnamon meaning my bag of
cocaine not for domestic violence or
animals we do have a home depot it's all
for my bag of cocaine
bag
a bag of coke
skinnerman
i love that a little super i love that
sticker
that's awesome super pear that's awesome
that's amazing
thank you
terry
yakuzzini watch the sandman are you
going to watch the salmon on your own
time i
yeah
i look there's some shows i have to i
had to have a whole conversation with
with the director actually that was
shadowing yesterday about it when he
pressured me into reacting to it yeah i
was like i don't want to react to this
stupid show man i want to just enjoy it
this is a spoiler just being here some
shows i i genuinely
i choose to watch on my own um and just
to
like you guys to exp some it's weirdly
important for me
it's weirdly important for me
to
have stuff that i also just watch on my
own and enjoy the way how you guys do
which is
you know eat food smoke drink whatever
the hell is it trying to be well-rounded
and then just binge something just binge
it and enjoy it
because that actually makes it you know
what it you know what it really is it
makes me more appreciative when we are
reacting to something
to share the experience than for that
but if it's
if it's always
being recorded
then it starts to feel like an act to me
after a while versus knowing that like
oh no i i know the genuine feeling of
watching something on my own and then i
gotta kind of uh
go into that mindset
when the camera's pointed
and so yeah i don't know it's kind of a
weird thing and yeah like naruto i'm i'm
uh i don't want to say exactly where i'm
at but i'm pretty far into shipping it
pretty far into there so yeah like watch
how i better call saul and uh
and westworld on my own quest barry is
another one that i really like they'd
all like i'll tell you it would have
made
great reactions
sure it would have oh god but i i
sometimes i like
just removing myself from the
exposure and the comments and just
enjoying some things on my own and then
you know
and yeah there are more horror movie
reactions coming i actually shot a
horror reaction with a roxy dryer for uh
the black phone boogie which is you know
i thought was going to be about the
invention of a telephone it's the
alexander graham bell buyer and i was
like what is this
70s what the hell is going on it's yeah
it's the original black inventor who
graham bell stole the design from
uh exodus
exodus
and i think some people kind of
understand where i'm coming from too
even with nope
i saw a couple of comments that were
like you know i get what you guys are
doing
but
i really kind of wish you just
experienced this for yourself in the
theaters for the first time and i was
like it's actually interesting reading
those comments yeah people who encourage
that i personally liked reacting
i loved reacting to it here um but i i
get that sentiment but some shows i'm
like you gotta understand any episode of
television
it's gonna take
many many hours to put together so
there's some shows i'm like i'm only
going to dedicate them i'm not going to
do every show and there's something i
just got to enjoy it as well
and any episode's going to take many
hours
exodus excited for your reaction to
sonic movie three in two years you bet
your damn ass gonna be out two years
right i'm not gonna watch it in the
theaters support cinema will they show
the military kill a 12 year old girl
with terminal illness what the [ __ ]
who knows i don't know but i appreciate
that your contribution to
heartbreak zero one no we're just on
recognizing the people right now because
everything they contribute is going to
charity yes death paul random thank you
thank you for your moment of silence
trey porter sup guys happy birthday john
thank you it's my day it's john's day
today
anime
i woke up to no messages at midnight
and
uh up to a ton i was like my phone will
not stop ringing keep saying happy
birthday greg
john you didn't text me at midnight
i was working on apollo 13
i texted you though
john texting me at 103 pm
i'm sorry i should have said alarm
girlfriend would have done that i know
now i'm gonna go see if you texted me at
midnight my birthday you're gonna go
through your
365 text messages
right now let me see here
jesus john right now i have oh god oh i
only have 204 text [ __ ] messages
thank you brian k says uh happy birthday
thank you so much trey porter was
apparently not making a sarcastic quick
i said i mean greg my bad it's okay it's
okay absolutely it's it's fine
have we seen bill murray in person
i wish that'd be crazy i'd be like look
at oldies
yeah he's getting old now would be my
thought sadly dashio milner greg is
actually
78.
he
just ages like
kion oh
thank you thank you very much keanu
appreciates your contribution to charity
as well whoa
rc gaming
you know my favorite charity
contributions are when um i remember
seeing this for it's not a slight
against johnny depp this is before an
amber [ __ ] um
so the when he like gave a bunch to
charity
and then there was like this
like this recorded
just super expensive ceremony to honor
him for his contribution to charity oh
goody i was like wait a minute
this kind of seems to go against the
whole point
it's like drinks celebration tons of
money bunch of cameras going into an
event to celebrate someone who gave
money to charity i'm like shouldn't all
this money just be going to the charity
see
like i would turn that down perspective
i feel like that would be very strange
it just doesn't make sense to me to do
that yeah i don't know like not to get
all jesus christ on you but i feel like
that's the kind of thing that you are
supposed to do without calling attention
to yourself like what we're doing right
now yeah totally
well it's different i think if you're
fundraising at the time but uh at the
same time it should be like the keanu
way where it's like aft years later you
find out like oh damn anonymous or they
try to keep this donation anonymous but
it turns out he gave a bunch to
children's awesome to me it's like if
you don't give anonymously it's fine uh
to me it's more like i don't get how you
would take all this money than anything
and then create a big asset make a
production yeah
no that money shouldn't be going to that
you should if you're in that position
absolutely send that money to the
charity as well but i guess one one way
of thinking is like look your favorite
celebrity is giving all this money to
this charity you should too i guess
maybe it's an investment uh that's the
only other way to see him perhaps that
is the way of thinking uh john
constantine in the chat just just
you know dcau
he's got more familiarity than me uh i
would love to check out some of that
stuff hopefully that answers your
question i've seen a few of them but uh
please
do we don't want to boot you can we see
the stream labs i want to make sure
because we we have to put the stuff on
pause uh pretty soon to
the super chats but um i want to i want
to confirm here
greg you're for 49ers still fetus miss
malevolent no you're a gorgeous human
being
i can't say the n word tlg black slater
nor do i think you two should be hiding
that
unless of course white people have been
using it a lot
sorry this course is common that is uh
oh my god john you have not been doing
your job what did i do we have
three stream labs
yes
we do let's read them let's read them
aloud let's read them all right we're
back in in black
black actors dave
a lazy rain am i
saying
[Music]
cremation takes its
piece of your supply
and china's on the dark side of the moon
get it up
hudsonizer happy birthday
i lost a gregorian sir john
and something of a royal myself i will
not be elaborating
i am not in you both
have you all seen the owl house
it's a kids show
but it's uh
avatar the last airbender level good no
i have not seen the owl house but uh
yeah that i i'm sure it's a great one
regardless
your request means a lot and your
contribution charity today means a lot
means more means more means more means a
real-life difference you know it's great
before i ever get these long-winded
explanations about you know turning down
a request
but now i can just be like sorry not
going to do it but your contribution to
charity means a lot worse
other regular live streams it's like
oh [ __ ]
now i feel like i have to do it
because the money's going to us and
that's charity now i got to spend
exponentially more time on [ __ ]
how much of an answer do you guys uh you
know like when you when you contribute
so kindly as you do what kind of answer
do you expect do you expect like a quick
address or do you want
you know your full do you expect your
full time i think like a comic-con
question i think it all depends on how
much money people have given that's the
also the value of a human being
generally is how much money they have
totally you know i believe that i think
if you um if you really want to know
yourself worth living thank you
[Laughter]
oh yeah
that's life advice you can take to the
bank the jdb people though
the josh
dude brolin uh
oh no no john daniel busby there you go
happy birthday greg that's me i'm greg
uh i've been watching you guys since you
were on new rockstars that one time oh
my god we actually got a single
subscriber from there yes you guys are
the best
my favorite channel on the tube
more than new rock stars also if you
haven't yet you should watch that last
time we were just talking about this
um
it is incredible
i've heard ted last was amazing you
might cry
yeah oh my god you know that's why you
should react to it oh my god do you
think i would cry have you seen it i've
seen a lot of time last year oh my god
really
see ted lasso sounds like the kind of
show i'd be interested in reacting to
it's a very heartwarming and a very sort
of life-affirming show is it yeah it's
very positive despite the amount of you
know difficulties the characters face
and it might move you but i don't like
what jason sedakis said about florence
pew and trying to get shia labeouf back
on the set of don't worry darling
and how he's dating harry styles i don't
like how he's doing any of that yeah
dude leave harry alone yeah he's missing
harry's not sure
i want to
you know
that's probably a good move and i felt
really bad for him when olivia wilde
uh subpoenaed him while he was like on
messed up that she did that to jason
sedakis messed up so messed up bro so
yeah but you know that's why it's
important to keep up with movie news and
get your information correctly
so thank you gtv fox
fox fox in the chat fox is an amazing
amazing human being thank you fox
uh that's right new rockstars number two
screw them coy stop going on their
channel yeah
rockstars we should stop reacting to
them too
love you both
thank you for all the laughs and
reminder that not everything is terrible
out in the world i know every time i'm
sure sometimes easy get caught up in
viruses
the homeless populations starving third
world countries
pollution
environmental disasters
taxation rising
criminal activities rising as well
brutality in law enforcement but every
once in a while it's good to just kind
of forget about all that [ __ ] you
know
who needs it you know doesn't it doesn't
help you maintain a positive attitude
all right john look i don't know i
wanted to do how do i think where you
put your hand down you go through it
bishop's knife trick yeah i wanted to do
it on the stream so
i'm gonna ask you to put your hand down
today good yeah yeah yeah let's do it
let's do it right now let's do it right
now and
thanks greg thank you for not slicing me
um
yeah man all right let's go back to the
um let's go back to the stream labs here
all right i mean the super chats lazy
we're going to keep the this open for
just like a few we've contributed we've
got a good amount of money raised so far
um we're going to keep it over just a
few minutes unfortunately you have to
set up for um i unfortunately
idiots their faults we can't raise more
yeah they hurt their fathers showing up
here
charitable country my my precious time
to help help do a fundraiser
what inconsiderate jerky jerks man they
don't care about the they don't care
about you know
people who are
who got some fighting words for ryan
aaron
hey ryan arie is amazing did he wish you
a happy birthday
yeah earlier than you
actually i think it was like four in the
morning when he wished me happy birthday
wow
and i said you're the new john and he
said i'm doing better at screen crush
he probably is
he's he's their whole channel that's
that's definitely true
oh hey we got vote votes to slice me in
the chat so that's good
thank you logan b
all right brittany thank you britney see
all right let's keep it going because i
saw a pretty big contribution here okay
um and i want to make sure we get to it
right there rc gaming happy birthday
greg you guys are my favorite youtubers
you yeah i swear to god rc gaming if i
go to another channel's live stream and
i see you put that [ __ ] down that
they're your favorites we're gonna have
some real issues i'm gonna feel you just
saying that's everyone that you buy our
love but thank you for contributing to
charity today
you're my favorite what
vishal vishu
here from jabbyverse
the jaby verse yeah dude what he calls
him and all the women multiverse of
japanese
oh yeah
doctor jab and the women shabby verse dr
t and the women
yeah yeah yeah wants to keep that one
can you imagine if when i was running
this channel
just me and i was like welcome to the
greg verse
john's part of the greg verse now i am
i'm a side character part of the group
we are just like other personalities
we wouldn't have these um he helped us
out everything with the road he helps
out a lot with the tech stuff yeah you
know every time there's a tech thing i'm
like talk to john
uh and then yeah he passes his
technology on to me i go okay i think i
get you and then i and then i make it
and then good enough that it works for
you guys yeah and now we have the road
caster here to stream comfortably
in fact um let's keep going secular monk
secular happy birthday greg 13 32 going
on 46. yeah man
dude my favorite uh jennifer
garner movie yeah it took you so long to
get there there are a lot of jennifer's
like i went to lawrence then i went to
walters then i went to lopez that i went
to
uh
garner
jennifer garner's last name just keeps
eluding me even then dude garner man
remember her and lecturer yeah
everyone's saying oh fine
jennifer walters so fine that's right
jennifer lopez ugly as [ __ ] yes as a as
a jennifer coolidge is so fine very fine
reminder jennifer lopez
bag of trash
[Laughter]
there's a lonely eye on the song let's
keep it there's a love song that's kind
of like that jennifer lopez is so so fun
so fun last week thought i saw you on
the street leia uh sir campbell happy
birthday greg thank you sarah i hope you
both are doing well i'm not but he is i
can't attest for john's feelings because
they don't matter today they don't
matter mine do and they're doing good
especially because you've contributed to
charity today thank you very much
charitable trust can't wait for people
to show up today and i could be just
super sarcastic
um thanks for coming to my party i guess
uh no i never could do the bend and snap
emily bert whistler you were correct
elya leah woman
said could be
check out has been hotel and hell of a
boss yes could be possibly good things
to react to dude to generate
more female subscribers
although you know what i'm genuinely i'm
actually genuinely interested in this
because i loved
the movie and no one else did i didn't
love the movie i really enjoyed the book
i didn't love it
but i really enjoyed this movie
vampire academy
and they have that was one of the first
things that started to do well in this
channel and i reacted to that and people
were like who's this random dude all the
the women who watch it like there's a
random guy who likes this
and uh
because everyone because i just came
across like some weird bro who liked
this trailer
and uh and uh uh i like the movie and i
have a peacock show coming out now which
has like a house of the dragon like
posters is like this epic crown
and i'm like i don't understand what
this maybe it's more accurate to the
source material but yeah i want to see
it
greg is older than your mom elijah race
um yeah i'm not older than you think
about that i would be interested in the
vamp academy show i'm very interested in
husband hotel and hell of a bus though
vivziepop is tearing it up and they're
doing that at uh a24 so i've seen a lisa
my friend who's an animator showed me
what's up erica showed me a preview of
has been hotel and it looks
it looks like quite an experience robert
o'neill you need a video of my hair for
your 12 year old son well it's been 32
years of always going into a store
and being like
hey i don't know what to do with my hair
and uh just did it again three days ago
and now it's falling in front of my head
instead of going up that's the new greg
the old new greg's the old greg back
just with a little bit sheen
yeah new greg is like old greg but
better um new recipe john we should
probably turn off the soups we should
probably turn off the super chats let's
go we're at the end and i have to set up
and go
set up today's one gift to myself is
making sure i don't get an anxiety
attack since i usually have anxiety
every day the minimum you could ask for
that's all i'm trying to do and so if i
don't have to rush
don't be everybody
that would be great all right but no
we've raised a pretty good amount of
money today you guys have raised a lot
of money today we got a really big you
turn it off yeah we didn't do anything
because we got it we got a few yeah i'm
not giving any of my own personal money
screw that
greg woke up today was like i don't want
to give a charitable donation how am i
gonna i don't know where to get the
fudge or
i'm gonna pay for this party
how am i gonna pay for the ceremony
where i show everyone how much i donated
taking out my time to raise money
time is worth
dedicating
i am donating time why should i get my
own now yeah it makes no logical sense i
donate my time which will become money
that will be donated yeah yeah
conqueror gang
[Laughter]
it's a good day today
we are all tired of being alone thought
i'd send love to john as well no don't
do that on greg's birthday i know i
enjoy the both of you here so here's
another 10. oh thanks oh thank you
conquer king thanks kang
thank you kang don't blame me i voted
for kodos
topicals
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh this is a juicy one it's a juicy one
you want me to read it i haven't read
any today but i feel like you have to
read them all because you're the
birthday boy you're in the hot seat
bucko all right john read it happy
birthday you look great for 46 years old
thanks for making great content you
john and coy are brilliant to what you
do and i hope you realize how much we
all love you but also shut up
this happened there i don't know
what what shut up about what is there
more
no no
just shut up shut up and take the love
that's that he's probably that [ __ ] just
happened flying buttress is anticipating
you being a humble harry and not wanting
to take the love and compliment but you
should so shut up and just accept it you
know but shouts out to you contributing
to cherry today
you always leave with that negative this
is
flying buttresses is a great example of
going through comment boxes
so many great things imagine this was
these were many comments divided up
you just read up like five positive
and then all you read is the one comment
that says shut up
that's what you end up leaving with it's
like oh my god this video is terrible
should i delete it what did i do wrong i
need to scream this video can you guys
watch this and tell me if there's
something wrong with it
scour the entire thing and make sure
that i didn't step wrong
happy 32nd birthday greg turned 27 today
myself hey happy birthday to you guys
that's good for you
i was saying shut up and take the love
okay never mind totally misread that see
i told you howard communication told you
uh thank you clarifies it weightlifted
off my shoulders thank you logan b happy
birthday to yourself buddy
are you using your birthday to raise
charity are you as good and humble love
as a person as myself
john didn't do this on his birthday i'm
better than john
and
yeah a little bit more of a simple 10 to
me you know what i mean
both of those were definitely the right
word
happy birthday greg
hi john oh hey my wife and i get high
and do the watch alongs with you guys a
lot good we're high now good y'all funny
but man we need that sandman watch along
i know what it's like to get fooled by
you guys
to be together just so you get enough
comments saying watch sandman then we
[ __ ] listen to the comments and then
no one's watching our videos
we've been in that trap many times
bringing
sandman
sandman is the one where part of the
back of my mind goes would it be worth
it
i mean i'm sure it make great reactions
but it is one i just want to watch on my
on my own there's there's so much coming
out this month guys we got cobra kai
season five lord of the rings to
continue which is starting off great
views are through the roof everyone
likes to dislike ratio oh my god 99
likes if you want to contribute to our
charity just leave a view
on especially episode two because this
show needs help
and uh and then d23
she-hulk continues how's
the dragon and or at the end of the
month we want to get some more movie
reactions going it's a lot you know and
one day we'll be in the blind way
position whereas i'm pretty sure blind
wave they just film
and do
everything awesome
like i would like that if it was just
filming if we just filmed we would do
everything yeah i'd be like screw this
[ __ ] sentimental [ __ ] of me
wanting to watch some stuff on my own
we'll put on a camera in my face let's
go
think about it you could put a camera in
any room of the house you have a screen
we're still very much involved with the
editing and the thumbnails and the
research and then we also do other
things a lot of times like we didn't
really do much in movie news last month
but probably picked that back up
but there's a lot coming out anyway
angel
coy is definitely 28. hope you're high
from the country
greg happy birthday thank you so much
i've been watching you guys for two
years i love the content and love your
guys's humor it's awesome hey hey
we love that you love us which makes me
feel love in my heart i love you the
easiest way to find love people is find
people who like you
and approve of your behavior because if
you can't self-validate yourself
you go looking for validation from
others yeah that
leads to gratification
thank you for your contribution charity
dj hamilton in the chat did does say
that you got way like even sexier since
you turned 46. thanks no it's that uh
it's that
silver backlining haircut yeah
you got silver in your in your curls i
got the silver in my beard i put the
silver on my ass hair today too
and uh stings
i like that you're prematurely dying
your hair gray it's got a perfect whole
body it's a mindset man
from the
master bird master bird one from one
greg to another hello other greg happy
birthday
it's mine also i'm 23. prove it so happy
birthday to you your 23 year old
birthday that's awesome man then thank
you thank you for your contribution
charity today and logan b super chats
are turned off we're just catching up on
a backlog
john say that but you can leave a super
sticker say the
turned on a vpn to donate because you're
my favorite marvel show
we're the lord of the rings shills this
week all right
you know sometimes it's really you know
what i'm struggling with it was so hard
for lord of the rings for me on and this
happens sometimes with the marvel stuff
it's like i tend to just go for like
what generated the biggest reaction it's
usually a positive emotion that
generates the biggest reaction but
sometimes that's on an episode that i
didn't even really like
and then you get to the review and i'm
like honest about it like i didn't
really like it
and i'm not trying to bait you into one
i'm like that's the biggest one so then
there was a real there's a real back and
forth with lord of the rings episode one
because i'm like this really looks like
i love this episode i liked episode two
a lot i didn't love episode one i was
very much like all right i loved episode
i didn't love episodes i liked episode
two a lot
and then episode one i'm like this is
really like that i gotta change it like
after an hour it being uploaded because
i was like well yeah
this is a feeling there's something just
off about this and and i need to find a
way
to show that i might not like you know
what i mean
yeah you guys know everyone deals with
the struggle right you guys make
thumbnails deals with this mental
contemplation
um you guys have to reduce the efficacy
of your video down to one image right
yeah thank you guys for all who have
contributed to the streaming live super
chat is all going to charity today and
thanks to everyone who's in disbelief
over greg's true age of 46. thank you to
all the women who are here too because
we don't know enough of you
joe cunha
thank you for the moment of silence oh
thanks joel
david ward oh my god
you guys seem so just talking about this
you guys seem so disheartened by rings
of power glad to see you guys can't keep
your rr's down especially as it's your
birthday love you both
well you know
charity calls
this is how we stop all domestic
violence and animals and needs of help
we just don't watch lord of the rings we
uh just give money
yeah
money is the key this is it right that's
all we got to do is how you do it that's
how you fix any problem the end of the
problem
somebody else will take that money and
do something about it
alex rucker
are you related to darius rucker from
hootie and the blowfish
46 is a cap but happy birthday but if i
had to guess i'd say 33
not too far off
just by 11 12 14 years but have you guys
thought about doing gaming streams
unless i just missed them
nah because i feel like if we did a
gaming stream i'd do it like like okay i
got like five i got like an hour into it
and now and now i'm like i i don't have
time to beat this game there's sort of
too much stuff coming out that i
prioritized be hard to keep those in any
way consistently yeah it'd be really
hard to keep that consistent you know
clinton tingler oh the tingler i like
your name happy womb evacuation day the
baby has evacuated pull the rip cord
the baby has evacuated
houston we have a baby
uh d akitay
happy birthday greg i wish more success
in your life i adore you guys
i don't need more success if anyone has
had enough success it's greg i feel like
i've been succeeding so much it's time
to start losing tired of succeeding
that's boring now nothing gets off more
than the thrill of losing it's really a
failure
composite frylock
i've been watching reaction videos for
10 years
we haven't been reacting for 10.
thanks for all the content
yeah yeah don't round up all right
do the do the math down to the day yeah
that's what a real fan yeah it's a real
fantasy we can't accept your charity
money yeah it's based on misinformation
tom dillon mcavoy john rita please happy
birthday greg
thank you for all you do to make a smile
your vulnerability on christian's
channel was so open and honest thank you
for that
enjoy your day dude
oh my god people bought it
enjoy your day dude who bought that
really you know i feel more
like i have more fun when i'm really
sarcastic and uh
i don't uh
i feel like that's the pocket i don't i
don't uh i get more like vulnerable and
real sometimes on other people's shows
you were very like sober and and well
spoken on christians
this is like oh this is like actors
studio right now
like we're getting thoughtful we're
really taking these topics seriously um
laughing here and there but but i don't
uh
i don't do that much because i have more
i don't know i feel like if i just kind
of took exactly what i've been doing
this whole stream if i went over to
there
i feel like it would just read weird
you know nah
nah always be the same
amanda hernandez
for morbius two
four more performances
happy 46th dude it is morbid time on
your birthday
do you still have any of the morbius
plasma g fuel brought to you by
all in 30 days that's messed up
i did throw away those posters
for g fuel oh for morbius you threw away
all of my morbius posters i threw them
away in the tree you could have recycled
them they came back stronger and more
powerful
[Music]
as they were destroyed
i gained their power jamie james 13.
idris from one mentizo to another
what is it
i'll be i'll be engineer uh matt gourley
and do a little uh
six years older than you oh wow
dj'd and after hours is super duper
early morning
i'm sorry
one of my guests paid to get it but
didn't want a refund
mestizo is a term might as well go to
your charity oh cool well thank you
mestizo is a term racial classification
to refer to a person of mixed european
and
indigenous american ancestry uh but in
countries in latin america it may also
refer to people who are just culturally
uh european in addition regardless wow
you did not profile me correctly because
i'm not that wow
wow
you're mixed race
european i mean there is you know italy
is in europe you actually do have a lot
of european i mean i think about it
you're from everywhere we it's on video
that's true i did do zenith go look at
our 23 and me
there's anyone who's mestizo it's me
the legend
you know for all you guys for saying you
don't look 40 you look like you're in
your late 20s and such like how johnny
shears just said that means a lot
because you know i think now is the time
for me to become an action star
dude you could do it you're like liam
neeson oh dude i'm just i i have said
that
i've said that so many times you're
about to enter your liam neeson phase
just the other day i was like my french
fries they were taken
and then i killed many people throughout
europe to get the religious will buy you
more like no i want the mice i wanted
the prize i specifically had custom made
for me yeah dude i think the mc will end
after secret war definitely they're done
making four billion dollars is too much
they're like we can't keep this god it's
not fair you gotta stop where are the
cats well
we had to
they're they're asleep
i don't want to make a jack you should
the fan film you should watch first is
spider-man lotus
uh joel thank you for all your
contributions to charity people joel
kunha
happy birthday greg all the best can't
wait to see your castaway reaction when
you're 82. i kid i've seen castaway it's
actually one of the five tom hanks
movies i've actually seen aha name them
all keep it keep it on i think the first
time that might have been
no i think the first tom hanks movie i
saw was saving private ryan the next one
was castaway i think castaway was the
second one i saw have you seen that
thing you do
no that could be a good one for the
ladies
really yeah it's uh i mean he's not the
star
yes that thing you do with the full
title is that thing you do with your
tongue when we're in bed together but
you know they couldn't put that on the
poster
it's funny actually that thing you do
which i haven't seen all of but i have a
vague recollection of i think he is more
of like a
he's not the main character
he's uh more of like the
not as crazy as an elvis but he's that
kind of figure in that movie i think
maybe
see you di akitay
thank you robin you go and
enjoy your enjoy your weekend especially
with your son
while you're one year older than me you
rules greg no you rules man oh you rules
wrote of edition's one of my favorite
movies of all time love to you in the
hospice section that is the lord's work
john loves going to the hospice i love a
hospice did we get sayyah did we get
this we did i just read it oh cool
you're all paying attention i was paying
attention to everything else anissa
oliva happy birthday gregor
lives we love you you beautiful human
i
love
i hope all your wishes come true my
friend well i don't win the lottery
tonight i'm going to blame you
and you have an amazing day today love
you and also john too we all know what
you really want is john's attention
that's sex appeal
sex appeal nah
sayad
i'm 45 we're both close to 50. i pray
for you by the way very much thank you i
need it
i am aging incredibly fast you are okay
thank you
yeah um jurassic world in here
lighthammer 66 thank you all coming here
saying happy birthday we are um
what the [ __ ] is with this gender
[ __ ] that i missed something
gender is a is a
is a construct that does exist on this
time so there's some people who probably
came into this chat
and like and they saw that poll and they
were like god this chat is all political
this
stream
for abuse victims and animals
thank you scott hansen yeah you're
awesome
you're a cuck lighthammer 66 i am a man
55 years of age happy birthday greg i
thought you were in your 30s she-hulk
twerk dude that was a great poem
i like this poem
i am a man
of oh you doing what the [ __ ] thing
john all right there we go what the [ __ ]
john all right all right there we go i
can't do it i don't know how to twerk
i don't know how to work you got to kind
of throw your ass and and oh oh john
knows
i i understand the concept
in the thighs you know i don't know if
that was anything i could look like you
were just running on your feet probably
but i feel like every time i've watched
a tutorial
this is well you know i mean you gotta
kind of throw the cheeks and kind of you
know like
i don't understand what's going on i
don't know we'll see
we'll see
we'll see in the playback when somebody
clips that inevitably ah
john's practiced he did uh you know i
mean i've wondered in the past i i've
seen enough twerks happen in my lifetime
what is the science that's why john gets
the one how does this work
you know i'll get it there someday
quentin anthony henderson oh that's so
many people
john please where's the
mcq
predictions thunderbolts as the cable
no cable that's okay they're all going
to be cable
three second earth appears at the end
of the two
loki two will largely be the mtu's
adaptation of time runs out i think so
this is a good theory i agree i think
loki two won't have anything to do with
what's going on your contribution to
charity
means the world that's right
thank you
excuse me guys i was up until 6 30 in
the morning
it's
slowly but surely what color of
underwear
oh yeah there he's got blue blue
underwear yeah
harvest
happy beating greg 46 and not a bit of
gray oh yeah except with the way i think
about opinions
that must be the asian blood that's greg
i'm john
or the baby's blood whatever you bathe
in is not for me to judge cheers to you
and john it's my blood he bathes in i
have to donate every month i bathe in
the blood
of abandoned children from the asian
countries
yeah i'll tell you man it's uh
it's a secret sauce i highly recommend
yeah
not so secret anymore
hey kawaii arcane masters thank you
friend oh
dude
for a second i thought you you were
saying that koi's mom was in the chat i
was like great erica
another birthday greeting from sweden
sweden also thank you both for many
years of great entertainment
entertainment one day i hope to make a
movie worth react to by you whoo
better yet i need to make a cameo dude
yeah we'll be cool man i really
appreciate that brother thank you thank
you eric yeah man make make movies i
think make a movie making movies is easy
make a movie about us that we'll cameo
in and react to that'd be great
greg and john strike back
that's what it is man we're gonna make
them eat our expletive deleted and then
we're gonna make them eat their
expletive deleted thank you best of luck
to you for real though thank you for
your contribution to charity today blue
flame studios
happy birthday greg
i hope you have a great
day
i'm working on it
very very grave the way that came
working on it man
yes absolutely
jeffy reacts back in the chat giving a
charity
jevy charity reacti happy birthday craig
thank you
thank you
guys people have been arguing this whole
live stream if i'm actually 46 or not
let me set the record straight it's
great for engaging i'm 46 years old born
september 3rd
watch me do it
i got this
i just got to figure out what it's
saying
it's actually a little bit harder than i
thought
1956.
no [ __ ] that's way too old what am i
talking about
wait a minute
no wait that's right isn't it 56
1956. no no no i'm one i'm going to eat
no no
66.
um
no 60 would put you 66
40 years after would be 2006 and then
six more years would be 2012
so you have to be 76 now
or 70 something for 46
to beat you to be 46 oh i've been adding
20 more years and not
14.
yeah i've been doing 22 000 yeah
yeah
my math was so off there i was close i
was like how do you do the difference
between 1990
yeah i was i was i was doing 32 plus 20.
that was yeah
you're right
um
hey clarissa oh clarissa what are you
doing
oh jon puts on sexy voice and talking
explain it hey hey how are you doing
i have not smoked i was working till six
and i mean not i was on set for
something so six in the morning so i'm
very very you were doing the hard work
last night 46
blow my mind
i must not be on hd hamster darby don't
be so
you're in 12k my dude
ange angle had the hipster i am a woman
in indigenous hey
i want to see you guys react to
reservation dogs i have heard incredible
things about that series reservation
dogs is great i've heard incredible
things about you've already seen it i've
seen a couple episodes what are you
doing they're two whole seasons i would
do not start watching things
without running it by me
are we gonna i would be overjoyed to
react to reservation dogs is it gonna
happen no it's too late
they're too late two seasons in i'm
sorry i stopped watching only murders
should i stop watching it can't watch
the show about indigenous people without
my white friend
ronaldo torres torres
greg buddy greg buddy can't thank you
enough because your inspiration i was
able to seek out help from my mental
health i think this stream has been a
great example of what mental health
achievements can do
now i'm happier than ever
happiest birthday
you deserve nothing but the best buddy i
appreciate that ronaldo please be sure
to keep
keep persisting and staying uh you know
very consistent with the mental health
game zade siddiqui who is your college
professor acting and reservation dog
sorry that caught my eye
michael madsen uh
john hell grieves jones moment of
silence thank you for contro
ricardo martinez gave a massive
contribution today to charity
said hello dude that's an adorable
profile picture amazing ricardo thank
you for your contribution today are you
the ricardo martinez from our patreon i
think so man you buddy i think so thank
you oh we got marco ton still from the
patreon great to see it's great to see
that love from charity today absolutely
just for charity in general yeah not
even a specific cause
shout out your favorite charities
general charity
general charity just discussing the idea
of being charitable today
i can't wait to pocket all this
the cherry run away with it escape town
fly flee fly up up and away web
it took off wait do we want a sunrise
original
charisma no no
hey yo i'm not sure if you guys watch
anime but
have you all watched fire force insane
also happy b day correct thanks for
making us happy urging charisma i have
not seen fire force i do watch um i do
watch anime um oh it's
occasionally not as uh frequent as i i
hope to i've seen a good amount
code
that got tidy
hey guys okay hey hey if you're a naruto
fan what am i saying what am i saying
you're calling somebody dumb or a
bastard or stupid or something
close
[Music]
gavin henthorne gavin henthorne happy
birthday you two are the best try the
new twilight zone i would but those
[ __ ] block like a total dick oh yeah
they are awful they are awful people
offer killer b you got it logan
yeah love you buddy you got it logan
knew we got it it was killer bee logan
it's fool you're fool
oh you're full fool you're fooled i feel
like there are multiple translations of
pacquiao
that's what they say
in this show i've put it on repeat how
many times i think it gets translated
for america differently depending on the
context of each scene well it's usually
something along those lines every time
it says that we've turned off the super
chats for now um weird because we have
to end this stream in like a couple
minutes
but we've raised a good amount of money
for charity day it's awesome um irish
viking you should check out
the last kingdom and vikings valhalla
happy birthday those are tools full you
fool that is right yeah i do not know
for sure
if we will but perhaps on my own time
we got a busy month a lot of people keep
forgetting that
many many hours this month it's gonna be
crazy yeah craziness all you all twenty
thousand views all twenty thousand
videos
daniel villanueva
you're 46 greg is daddy age oh dude 21
could be daddy age dude i've had parents
at younger ages than 30 you know it's
sad they throw their lives away and by
lives i mean all that partying and
drinking and drugs they started getting
like a job
settling down getting sober
setting goals what a bunch of [ __ ]
what i want to know is what is that
what's what's zaddy age i want to get to
a point where i'm zaddy age huh
jeff's good
[Music]
happy birthday and john the hair is
flowing baby god damn right man that's
what john does best he flows he lets his
hair flow that's right let it flow john
not always but sometimes
flow happy birthday brian
um pld
brian
lorenzo yeah what the hell yeah pfd
happy oh john for [ __ ] sake dude it's
right here bro happiest of birthdays my
friend here's to many more
i hope to have at least five more i'm
think i'm done because i think 51 is an
interesting age to go out
yeah join the 51 club i think that would
be good i think it'd be a good time
wait a minute didn't elvis die when he
was like 46 you could die now i don't
know i saw the movie
what do you think
you didn't wait to react to the music
copyright nightmare that would be elvish
you know that baz larman he don't like
to edit out [ __ ] nope
it's all in here
this is all the [ __ ] i share every angle
told me to shorten the run time so just
sped up some scenes
yeah i over cranked some [ __ ] just to
get some scenes out faster boom
everything's in there can't miss a bait
kids on the street um
i liked elvis a lot man that austin
burke he became elvis so much he still
has that accent yeah austin is a
youtuber
austin buffer shouts out to austin burke
austin butler um i know you watch the
special features and he's like oh yeah
it was crazy getting elvis's life you
know no you ain't watching any
interviews it's what it sounds like and
it's uh it's
it's um
not pretentious but real
he's good
i feel like i'm sure you could talk your
way back into sounding like a regular
person it's like been a couple years man
see a vocal dan lewis doesn't go on
interviews and he's like i'm daniel dave
lewis i am still in character after all
this time i have not been able to shake
my voice
i am no longer british no no no no what
happens is after every daniel day-lewis
role he has a different acting voice
coach come in and teach him how to speak
like daniel day-lewis so austin butler
is going to need that that's part of the
awesome mother thing that i'm like
look i get that it can stick around but
come on ramy malek dropped it you can
drop it too
lewis literally like lives and breathes
not in a hotel room
he's like i'm going to tent out for
there will be blood
you know yeah that's a whole other level
of commitment
he doesn't understand the power of
imagination he didn't use any of his
motor skills during my left foot he only
used his feet
only use his feet
isn't that with my left foot doesn't he
use this i haven't seen my left foot i
haven't too oh my god john reaction
reaction to my left foot
and we're gonna be like this is more
boring than i ever thought it would be
get a real my left foot reaction lasts
the mohicans reaction oh yeah yeah be
good gangs of new york reaction
i've never seen gangs in new york
i love gangs new york i know
this is a kill
casey rhodes thank you dasha um yeah i
would like to continue chucky i love
chucky bad medicine hi greg hi greg and
john thank you for trailblazing the way
for reactors we did not solve this guy
gator martin gator martin did gator
martin was actually the biggest opener
for most of us believe it or not
i'd love to pick your brain some time in
future on a few things well one you got
to have a good react face
you know are people going to want to see
you or you're going to be like i don't
like this person that are ugly
so first things first you got to be
great looking exceptional looking only
exceptional looking people can do
reactions
two
gotta learn to smile
smiling's important man
three
you become a master at uh adobe premiere
really nail that down four you gotta get
a sound designer
great lighting five makeup pair artists
we john i use one for every every video
and a cg budget and a green screen to
create you know some sort of backdrop
yes yes yes yes you gotta have um you're
definitely gonna have a whole crew there
you might need a bunch of crazy ass
lighting yeah but it's more have a
trailer you know you might need a rest
we actually shoot these on the
stagecraft thing now yeah yeah oh
catering service really good
crafty for every shoot all right let's
refresh these to read the stickers john
please do your thing aye aye capitano
gonna refresh and hey let's just do a
little more refresh on the streamlabs
just to make sure that nobody else
wanted to do a fee-free donation
all donations are are super uh aprice by
the way
oh oh my god we got more people in us
holy balls you guys really contributed
here
wowie oh my goodness gracious me i'm
half tempted to just take this money for
myself you should
what are what was i thinking today john
i don't know dude give my birthday money
to charity this is after the most
successful live stream we've been
successful you've done in a long time
what the [ __ ] giants
ah it's all my fault dude i'm sorry god
i should never have
i should never have forced you into this
position
with my woke pen i just wanted to raise
like 50 for charity
look how much more we're gonna have to
give away now ooh can we insert an ad
right now
youtube gives you these funny prompts
during your live stream hey guys happy
birthday greg first of all yes
i gave a hundred dollars that's a lot of
money that's uh that's a big the
charities will be grateful
the charities appreciate your efforts
they told us
you guys create such fun content and i
want to ask what advice would you give
to someone who wants to make contact in
this reaction department as well a
little nervous all right i'll give you a
real answer
the first thing i'd say is just work
with what you have
like what i always tell every guest who
comes by here
is whatever first of all try to limit
talking over when people are talking
um in like whatever you're watching
that's the i think that's the number one
thing that i know is people in reactions
the benefit of doing like the reaction
highlights and shows and movies is you
know like i still try not to not talk
over people or talking but if we do i
can just cut out the footage and it
doesn't look like i'm talking to people
so um but if you're doing like trailers
or something you know like that's an
important rule of thumb secondly i
always say like
um whatever you're thinking or feeling
internally you know like uh let it out
express it
you know in some way it can be with
words you don't want to like go into
monologuing or something but you know uh
really let that side of you show the
side of you that doesn't that often kind
of stays within like a lot of time for
me i feel like there's a sense of
freedom with having a camera to feel
like i can express myself more
so i i think that is like such an
integral part and it weirdly does kind
of link to like what actors say i think
that would like
the camera rolls they feel like they
they're a little bit more free to
express themselves that's kind of what's
happening here
you know whereas like some people have
the idea of this isn't what it looks
like when you're in your living room by
yourself
and i'm like no that's not really the
point the point is to to to
you know
let that side of you out you know to
show that
and it doesn't have to be like massively
bigger all the time you know that's like
the main thing secondly a lot of people
get caught up in like tech stuff and i
say start with what you have like when i
started doing reactions here it was
literally everything was off of the
laptop
everything shitty camera on the laptop
shitty sound edited on imovie everything
started with that so don't be afraid to
start with what you have if it's a
decent enough webcam better than what
was started here so yeah like just
i'm talking i usually the lap like the
one you would do like funny photos on
photo booth to it like that's what i
started with so um yeah just do that man
do that yeah uh and just have fun main
thing and then you can incl
incrementally grow your skills as you
acquire better equipment yeah now we got
to give like really efficient answers
definitely and uh
brian perry what's up dude brian perry
um thank you for contributing chair
today hey it's me brian your favorite
fifteen dollar patron what's going on
man yep here's another 15 on the hopes
that will go to someone who actually
deserves it and it absolutely will burn
kidding of course love you guys it'll go
to people much more deserving than us
we are doing fine financially right now
so let's give this money to people who
deserve it
kept me smiling after a seriously rough
couple months oh that means a lot man
much love and happy birthday girl thank
you brian that's really really really
really kind of thank you very generous
sir alan smithy
oh love your movies
yo greg hey john have to beat dick
gregor 46 2 march 76 boom bada bing 46
years old you look much younger than i
do what are you doing huh you touching
yourself a lot at night love meeting you
guys last year spectacular was a good
time i was the guy with the beard in the
shoes remember the guy with the beard in
the shoes with a very rare breed out
here anyway party on guys and keep it
real remember beard and shoes you don't
see a lot of those two combinations out
there
i do remember talking to somebody who
had a beard and was also wearing shoes
and i bet that was you thank you man
knowing hugs uh if you're 46 and i am a
fetus well you're a damn good fetus that
i'm going to groom
thank you
get him on
the
tmz
flying buttress hi greg my earlier super
chat was misinterpreted no
we eventually interpreted correctly i
thought it would be fantastic if i ended
it with but also shut up i have since
learned that this is the internet don't
do that so happy birthday you guys are
great yadda yadda but also shut up
perfectly done i appreciate plus comedy
you [ __ ] rock thank you thank you for
giving to charity today love you lorenzo
baxter hellbacks
there i finally made it to a stream i
told you i don't just watch core
reactions baxter booyah thank you
lorenzo uh uh for legend of core
reactions lorenzo baxter on top of the
comment game and the feedback the
in-depth feedback for legend of core
reactions thank you and thank you for
giving it to charity today means a lot
that's right let's read off this uh is
there anything more in here
okay we are going
all right
let's go give it a charity i'm really
proud of you guys thank you read the
final stream labs for the day oh my god
today's my birthday as well happy fellow
b day greg i just got back from seeing
no way home again with my sister i know
i made a billion dollars and everyone
loves we could use that money you paid
to see no way homie give it a charity
but i feel like we still don't talk
about it enough movie is a miracle
it really is especially when you see the
mixed bag reaction that marvel's been
getting lately but you're like god damn
they nailed that no way home that's a
good point
kawaii arcade masters mr tisa from miss
tisa i'm also mixed but no happy
birthday greg keep up the good work with
john that's all i do all i care about is
keeping up the good work with john right
here right now with john oh i go this is
the good work my work means nothing if
it's not ended up with jon
oh yeah that's right always always
always pacing behind that shot
yep that's how reality in our lives
works keep up with john keeping up with
me always
kate vande i'm 46 47 one year from now
um let's go back to the super chats
let's do let's get soup and we gotta end
this man
we're bowling pursue well you guys are
giving so much today that is awesome i
can't wait to screenshot the final
receipt given out uh to the charity you
guys were like twenty dollars like yeah
man you know to cover the cost of
putting this live stream together yeah
all right all right
we got it
uh joel
yep one movie does not exist yet that
you would love to react to in the future
happy birthday i would love to skip
avengers secret wars in theaters and go
[ __ ] the crowd here's what it's like to
watch this movie in real time without a
crowd manipulating you this is rushed
there's too many characters
can't latch on to anybody it's just a
bunch of action it's just a bunch of
action this should have this secret war
should have been three movies and they
rushed it all right don't listen to
crowds who are cheering and hooper and
hollering but it's actually distracting
you from how terrible of a film this is
i vote for morbius 2. slo-mo panda sweet
gamer sweet home squid game squid game
what is sweet home i don't know don't
time to look it up unfortunately that's
why we're going
to cringle berry yeah no i mean that's
why the uh the person who gave like a
hundred bucks in streamlabs was awesome
because
youtube takes like uh like we're saying
like ninety percent uh terrible your
parents let the doctors name you a male
did you have any choice in the matter
hank um i i did i did i came out it was
like guys
my original name was craig craig said i
hate that name craig
i want to be called
greg
they were like yeah
and i said
this joke could have been better all
right carlos lima yeah thank you for the
sticker friend oh look at that thanks
for being you says the stick that's very
adorable look at that it's admiring
yourself in the mirror
party dance oh we got a couple party
dances
you guys giving a charity means a lot
you got good people here in the reject
nation robin o'neill thanks thanks to
you marco ton still oh yeah
from the patreon
susan say how's it going oh i like the
good season
oh it takes extra time to talk to the
girl and that's nice blue falcon 24 7. i
like this critical hit video trying
control i've tried with everybody don't
try you're sending more to the females i
get it you're trying to seduce them
right now and it's working it's working
on me too casey rhodes
cake
the birthday cake that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense
that's amazing amazing and george sussex
we did it guys happy lemon all you guys
contributed so much to charity lavery
adam i saw another little winky face
dick that's awesome looking out i
appreciate you guys for all you
contributed today um and thank you i
know
we lured you with my birthday oh and
lavery adam as well oh no you got two
lavrov giving it all away
give it away give it away give it away
now
you can see you can do the wrong doing
it you're like stumbling through a pile
of like trash it's hard for boxes
[Music]
[Music]
doing
just wait try it it's hard
now it's hard
and that's the letter i i could always
roll was like the more you know d t
sound letter like r took me forever to
learn how to roll and i'm still not that
good give her away give her away give
her away now so good i know he's rolling
a t that makes no sense what are you
talking about i think he just anyway
guys thank you so much for being here
thank you for all you guys contributed
uh we'll post the the final i might give
it all the one
or i might you're annoying screw you
daniel griffin screw you screw you i've
seen your name in here so many times and
now you're back and screw you but i
appreciate you being here and helping
out with the engagement so i love you
daniel you for letting us you're
actually an all right guy daniel thanks
for watching see that's called character
arc and empathy practice it sometimes
anyway guys
we are done
we will see you guys
see you guys soon much love to everyone
out there and thank you for all for you
donate and i'll screenshot a receipt on
uh
probably tomorrow or monday thank you
guys gotta wait for the [ __ ]
analytics to tell me how much was made
so
thank you guys
peace and love peace